well he struggles from the rapid and
bliss continuing I continued with a loss
at least on the first day but since then
a couple of drawers Wesley it looks like
you're riding the ship a little bit what
are your feelings so far after the first
three rounds
I'm well to be honest I wasn't feeling
very well yesterday he didn't help to
know the fact that I miss some doors in
my game against check in quite a
difficult position
so yeah wasn't feeling very well I'm
still very happy to be in the tournament
you know I just gotta keep fighting
and I got I mean I really need to play
better chess you know because from some
of the moves I didn't disturb and just
unforgivable but again every all the top
chess players are here so I'm very
pleased to be in the thing in the same
term as them why you're one of the top
players in the world so well deserved of
course what about today's game it seemed
like you need neutralized pretty pretty
easily he played this idea with East six
surprise to you yeah well ethics looks
like the most natural move I've seen
that Maxim has recently tried to knock
the Berlin wall down again he has played
quite a few games in the rapid and this
with in the Berlin endgame so I wasn't
sure if it's got played he was gonna
play the Yoko piano with Bishop c4 and
I've never really played this system
before this Bishop e7 and nine h4 but
LaVon has played it and it seems to hold
up pretty well because many most of the
pieces are exchanged and in fact if he
didn't play a six it's not easy for
white to make progress because all these
troops on the center and it's bishop is
geared towards this break but yes so he
played a six take take
but then I think the petition was most
equal at this point perhaps I could say
even more accurately by the way if we
played it seems to hope the problems for
the most part yeah it seems like a very
tedious game but in fact I have to be a
bit careful here because if before the
well even before the rooks were traded
you see rook is very active on the fifth
Frank and I have to be careful of h4 an
f4 idea so like I have to be very
careful not to not to get worse and see
like you solved all your problems but
you still have the challenge of getting
to London and that has become slightly
problematic after your performance in
the st. Louis rapid think about the
London because I just try to take it one
term at a time I mean it for example if
I if I win this tournament then I don't
mind not going to London I mean of
course I want to be in London but there
are other tournaments I wanted to go to
the one who deserves it the most and I
just have to do well in every tournament
actually I mean doesn't matter if I
clean London or play in the Las Vegas
open or in world it I just have to play
my best chess because there's no point
joining if my games are gonna be
second-rate food with that in mind I
think we have to play much better chest
yes you know I'm feeling a huge turbo in
this in this tournament by the way if I
gotta keep that in mind
all right well professional attitude
indeed you're right if you play well the
rest will take care of itself thanks for
joining us and we wish you the best
playing well thank you Mary